And now to you, Scoutmaster
David. is there anything that we missed that you'd like to tell people about?
Uh, not that I can think of.
You're going to get your eagle. you're going to state it publicly.
you're going to get your eagle before the HF is.
I am going to get my eagle.
I have one more meeting for a merit badge
and then I'm done with all the required merit badges
and that's the last requirement I have left.
So I'm right there.
Alright, let's see how good I am. alright,
It's an eagle-required merit badge.
You have one more meeting left for it, and it is family life.
No, it is not.
Alright, wait a minute, I've got another chance.
It's got to be a 90-day wonder.
Yeah, it's got to be personal management.
Nope,
Oh man.
Alright, David, what is it?
Oh, it's for citizenship in the community.
Oh, come on.
So you were a good boy and you did family life
and personal management a long time ago.
I did actually.
Okay,
Alright, well,
Did you fill out your Boyce Gear Eagle Scout workbook?
I have completed that.
I'm going to let you know when David finishes his
Scoutmaster Conference for Eagles.
Okay,
David, do you have enough people breathing down your neck yet,
Or not?
I mean,
I'm getting to the limit.
Yeah,
Hey, this is podcast number 83..
Hey, welcome back to the Scoutmaster Podcast.
This is Clark Green.
You're going to hear a little bit more from the fellas
that we heard from just a moment ago before the theme
Later on in the podcast. it was part of an interview
that I conducted, but more about that later.
Let's take a look and see who's been in touch
over the past week.
I heard this from Mark Craner.
Mark is a Scoutmaster down in Texas
and he wrote a post on the blog this week
at scoutmastercgcom that talked about opportunities
and he said
That post really hit home with me, Clark.
As a Scoutmaster, I often find myself concentrating
on the few Scouts missing out,
as if I failed to bring them into the fold.
You're very right.
We need to encourage and then step back
and let Scouts make their decisions.
It's such a joy to see Scouts who are first reluctant
find their way back into Scouting
and so on, to do great things.
Thanks for this post.
It was just what I needed to hear.
Well, thanks for being in touch, Mark.
I'm glad that you found that useful.
Frank Maynard was in touch about last week's podcast-
podcast number 82, in which we talked a little bit
about discipline in Scouting
and we also talked about Scoutmaster conferences,
in response to a couple of emails we had received,
and he said this podcast was chock-full
of great information for Scoutmasters.
I wish this material was covered as thoroughly
in Scoutmaster Leader-specific training.
I'm recommending it as a must-listen
for our troops Scoutmaster
and our assistant Scoutmasters.
Well thanks, Frank.
Once again, it's always good to hear from folks
and that they're finding the information
that we're putting out useful.
I also heard from Josh Ney.
Now Josh is a Scoutmaster of Troop 44
in Glen Olden, PA,
and he said: hello there.
I subscribe to your blog
and I thoroughly enjoy your posts.
I noticed that you are not all that far away
in southeastern Pennsylvania.
I'm about 40 minutes away
and I hope to meet you sometime at an event in our area.
Well, Josh, the feeling's mutual.
We're not in the same council,
We're not in the same county.
No right,
You could run into somebody.
It's always good to hear from folks,
whether you're from across the country
or from the next county away.
Do be in touch
and you can email me, Clark Green,
at ScoutmasterCG at Verizonnet.
Now. this is that time of year
when the fall program
is getting ready to start.
in our packs and troops and crews.
I know that our troop
has got a full slate of activities
and we've got some- you know-
council and district stuff coming up,
so we're going to have a very busy
and, I'm sure, satisfying fall and spring.
But let me ask you this question:
What are you going to do next summer?
What are your plans?
You know most of us will probably end up
going for a week at Scout Camp
and everything like that.
but how about an additional adventure,
And that's the focus of our podcast this week,
Out there in Sunnyvale, California,
is a troop- troop number 466,
and they have an assistant scout master
named Mike Malone
who has put together just some really amazing
once in a lifetime adventures for their scouts.
I had the opportunity to sit down with Mike
and a life scout from their troop, David,
and we had an interview
and we talked for a while about the adventure
that they went on this summer,
which was a recreation of part
of the Lewis and Clark expedition
out in Montana,
and talked a little bit about how you make that happen
and what the youth role is
in making stuff like that happen,
and it's meant to inspire you to start thinking big
and to start thinking about that once in a lifetime adventure
that you're going to create
in the coming months and maybe years.
And, as you'll hear Mike say,
you just need to have the brass,
you have to have the moxie
to say, hey, we're going to make this happen,
and you get people on board
and then, wow, you can do some pretty amazing things.
And we're going to talk all about that here
in just a moment
and that's going to take up the rest of the podcast.
So let's get started, shall we?
I've got a couple of guests joining us
on the Scoutmaster podcast today
and I think you're going to be very interested
in the story they have to tell.
Mike Malone has been involved in scouting
since he joined as a boy
way back in 1965,
and he went on to become a 13-year-old Eagle Scout.
and, for those of you guys who go way, way back,
Mike was a chapter commander
in the Knights of Dunamis,
which was a precursor to the National Eagle Scout Association.
So if you remember the Knights of Dunamis,
you go way, way back.
We're almost all dead now.
Well, you're still kicking.
You're still doing pretty good, Mike.
Mike returned to scouting with his older son in 2001
and since then has served as an assistant scoutmaster
for Troop 466 in Sunnyvale, California,
And I've got him talking to us today
about organizing and leading
some once-in-a-lifetime adventures.
How you doing, Mike?
I'm good. How are you?
I'm doing okay.
We also managed to get David Bauer,
who is a life scout in Troop 466..
Still a life scout, David?
Yes, I am
Almost there.
I actually have one last requirement for Eagle
and then I'll be done with that,
And you are 17 and 10 months,
Yes, 17.
And 10 months.
Yeah, about that,
Right around there.
See, I didn't even have to.
That's just,
That's 25 years of experience talking right there. folks,
I knew that somehow.
So, David, tell me about this once-in-a-lifetime adventure this summer.
Well, we flew out to Great Falls, Montana,
Went to the Montana State Fair
and we did a flag ceremony at the State Fair,
Just spent a couple of days in Great Falls
and then on Sunday the boat,
the replica of the Lewis and Clark Bat-Toe, was delivered to us
and we loaded that up on a trailer
and on Monday we transported it out to a campsite right on the river
where we met up with some Lewis and Clark re-enactors
who taught us some basics, like on how to make fires
and what they ate when they were out on the trail
and things like that,
And so we camped that night
and then we spent the next couple of days
on the river in canoes and on the boat,
and we did a total of over 50 miles in three days on the river,
and each day we stopped at one place for lunch
and would do a little side hike or something like that,
And then on the last day when we got out of the river
then we drove back to Great Falls
and the next day we did a handing-over ceremony
for the Lewis and Clark Interpretive Center
and we donated them the Bat-Toe.
Over the next couple of days we worked on my Eagle Project,
which was to build a stand and display for the boat,
and that ended on Saturday.
and that was pretty much it. It was really fun.
So tell me about this Bat-Toe,
Describe it to me.
It was a 25 foot long keel boat,
completely period, accurate material, so it's all wood-
and it had a one square sail that we put up and down on the mast,
which the mast also went up and down to aid for transporting it,
and had room for four people to row
and one person on an oar in the back to help steer,
and the entire thing weighed over 900 pounds.
So where in the world does a person find a Bat-Toe anymore?
We had it made from the Buffalo Maritime Center in New York.
Wow,
So once in a lifetime,
Definitely.
What do you most remember from this trip?
I'll probably remember most detail, but later on will be
when the last group in the Bat-Toe missed the takeout
on the final day on the river, and, being a couple other scouts,
we ended up running down the bank of the river
and jumping into the river and dragging it back upstream
for a quarter mile and then holding it in the water
next to the takeout while we tried to get it loaded up
under the trailer for probably half an hour.
Yeah, just 900 pounds.
Yeah, only 900 pounds.
Yeah, no big deal. You got that right,
Of course.
And what river were you on?
The Missouri River,
And so obviously you guys were recreating a piece
of the Lewis and Clark expedition.
Yes,
Did you acknowledge about it before you went?
Prior to the trip, the only things I knew about Lewis and Clark
were stuff I'd learned in school and things like that.
But once I learned about what this trip was going to be focused on,
I watched a documentary and did some research
on what Lewis and Clark did when they were in the area,
like that stretch of the river that we were going to be on,
just to kind of see how their trip went during that portion.
And how did their trip go About? like yours?
Well, they spent over a month
portaging around all the falls and great falls,
and we just did a float trip a little north of that.
There was a lot harder than ours was,
but we were going downstream too,
so it would have been on the way back from their journey,
And on the way back they were doing upwards of 60 miles in a day.
so that was completely different than what we were doing,
because we were doing usually between 10 and 15,
and completely different gear and stuff.
But it was just interesting because we were on the same river
that they were on and we stayed at some of the same campsites
that they stayed at. so it was like in touch with history.
And how many people were on the trip?
I believe 27 people, including Dad.
That's a pretty good size group.
This is one of a series of four annual adventures
that Troop 466 has done
and, Mike, you've been involved in planning all of those
and putting those together
and you put lots of links in the post that contains this podcast
so people can learn about them in more detail,
because they really are fantastic.
What was the first one, Mike?
We traveled to the UK and we did the Wainwright Walk,
which was a walk created by a rather eccentric English gentleman,
And he sat down one day and said:
I wonder if I could walk all the way across this country
on existing trails and private paths.
And he created the Wainwright Walk.
I was up near the Scottish border in the Lake District
and ended up on the North Sea at Robinswood Bay,
and it's 193 miles.
I had a group of overachiever older scouts.
I found myself in a position of being an assistant scout master
in charge of the older scouts.
We have something called a bank patrol
and these are all scouts that are typically
have been patrol leaders.
They finish that. they're working towards their eagle.
they hold senior positions in the troop
and a separate existence for them beyond the troop.
So they're still at the troop meetings,
but we have Vanguard patrol meetings at a restaurant.
They wear a suit and tie
and we're trying to teach them more adult skills
and give them more adult experiences to keep them engaged.
We do a lot of air badges.
We do a lot of other things.
I was kind of driven to create something
that would be so compelling that these older kids-
and these kids are going off to Berkeley and Trinity
and UC San Diego-
give them something that would keep them engaged in the troop
now that they had their eagle.
And so this trip was just five scouts,
two dads for half the trip
and then just me for the other half,
And we hiked at 193 miles across the country.
It was kind of elegant camping
because we stayed in people's houses every night.
We finished that we went down to the World Jamboree
and in the midst of all that
we also took a train down to the channel
and went to Brown Sea Island
for the 100th anniversary of the original.
That was 2007, then
2007..
Well, that sort of set a precedent.
The next year I felt obliged to come up with something
equally interesting
And, as it happens, I inherited a farm,
my great-grandfather's original landrush farm,
just outside of Enid, Oklahoma.
I surveyed the train tracks along the Chisholm Trail
in the 1890s.
I read about Chisholm Trail, cattle drives,
reenactments of them-
There's only been one big one-
And I contacted the woman whose father had been the cowboy on it
and I said: can we put something together?
She got together a group of cowboys
and a Catholic priest was the chuck wagon master,
and when they brought along a chuck wagon with mules
and gathered up horses for us,
rode 50 miles up the Chisholm Trail
and towards the end of the trip we drove cattle
And most of these boys had never been on a horse before
And we camped on, you know, out on the stars every night
and we had guest speakers and musicians.
It was fairly arduous,
but the boys had an amazing experience
That compelled us to do another one.
So luckily they went to Fillmont the next year,
which brought me a little bit of time.
The subsequent year we did a Civil War experience.
So we went to Northern Virginia
and we went out to the Balls Bluff Battlefield-
and David was along on that one too,
And a couple of his buddies were doing their Eagle projects,
in fact- and we essentially restored the Balls Bluff Battlefield.
We cleaned up the cemetery, planted new grass,
scrubbed the gravestones,
We finished that. and then we were immediately taken
as involuntary enlistees into a Union unit
And one night we were taken out by the Confederates
and we were captured and taken out at Skirmish
And then we camped with some reenactors
from the California Brigade of the Pennsylvania Regiment,
And these guys came out from Pennsylvania
and we camped on the grounds of an antebellum mansion
And we practiced drills and fired rifles
and learned all about that.
We went up to Gettysburg, had a college professor
and authored gave us a long lecture on the California Brigade
during the Battle of Gettysburg.
We walked to Pickett's Charge,
I should mention. we began the trip by marching in the parade
on the Capitol Mall.
We finished at the National Jamboree
where, in our Civil War uniforms,
we conducted the flag ceremony on VIP Day
and one of our scouts handed the Chief Scout Executive
a big photo of the day.
So that was quite the finish too.
So, David, you got to do the trip to Leesburg and everything.
Yes, I was on that one.
What do you remember from that one?
One thing that always stuck out was the heat
when we were doing the first parade.
when we first entered
It was just the whole
Being in full Class A and 90 degree weather
and then 90% humidity was not that great.
But some guy did do the parade in a bomb suit
because they had Eagle Scouts
that were supposed to dress as their profession
and he was a U of D guy in the military,
so he did the parade in a bomb suit
and then I kind of felt lame afterwards looking at him.
You know, Mike, where do you even get started
with something like this?
I think a lot of people have these kind of ideas,
maybe that this would be a great thing
to be able to do some kind of adventure,
but few of them come to reality.
What elements have to be there
to make something like this happen?
I've turned into a fairly systematic process at this point,
but there's always a large element of serendipity
and the unexpected.
So I feel like the Scouts have always needed
that historic dimension.
So I'm very interested in giving the boys
some sort of contextual experience
of American history or world history,
And that is to say, I want them to be 40 years old
and sitting in a bar somewhere at home watching TV,
and they show on the television cowboys, Red River
and they're driving the cattle across the Sinron River
and they can say to themselves:
I know what that was like, I know what that felt like.
I've done it
Each time. I begin with a kernel of a notion of history
and then try to build out from there.
The Lewis and Clark one came really because
I used to run a magazine called 4JFAT.
Stephen Ambrose was one of my writers on occasion
And he wrote the great Lewis and Clark book
and once he invited me he said:
come up to me at the Montana,
Let's float down the Missouri River through the Missouri Breaks.
Unfortunately I didn't take him up on it and he's gone now,
But it always went back in my mind.
I thought a Lewis and Clark experience would really be something.
So, beginning with that, you know none of an idea-
I began to build outwards.
So I began to research Lewis and Clark
and what kind of boats they had,
And they were using these two,
what they described in the journals as bat toes.
So I began looking at bat toes
and I discovered that there was a program
at the Buffalo Maritime Center of State New York,
on the lake there in Lake Erie,
and they built a bat toe.
So I contacted Roger Allen there,
the guy who builds them,
And he said: yeah, love to.
Actually, an Eagle Scout and some other scouts
helped on building the boat there.
It was a perfect replica.
Now, simultaneously I had to figure out
what service can we do.
Creating a historic trail on the river would be one thing
And another scout on the troop took that one.
David wanted to do something physical,
He wanted to build something.
Well, I got a hold of the Lewis and Clark
Interpretive Center in Great Falls
and I said: are you guys interested
in receiving a bat toe as your new exhibit?
And they were high on the idea.
So I connected David with Roger Allen in Buffalo
and with the Lewis and Clark Interpretive Center people
And I just sort of stepped back
from that part of the process
And David worked out with them
how to build a cradle for the bat toe
and all of that.
And he also helped with getting the boat,
arranging it to get it to Great Falls.
But now we had all of that put together.
So the next thing was: could I get people in Great Falls
to help us help the bullies learn?
And we ended up with a whole group
of Lewis and Clark re-enactors
who came out on three different occasions
and gave extended presentations
and showed what kind of food they ate.
Trappers came and showed furs.
They showed the rifles and the pistols
and the weapons.
It was really quiet.
It was a Native American re-enactor
who came and talked about the history of the tribes there
And so the boys got a real full immersion
in this before and after. we went on the river,
In the river itself.
most of these boys had never been on a canoe on a river
And the bat toe. none of us knew how to sail,
We didn't have a rudder,
It had a stern sweep and great big bore.
So we literally learned as we went along the river
And there was no way off that river
for those 53 miles.
The river was quite spectacular.
I mean, we were staying, as David said,
staying in the campgrounds where Lewis and Clark camped,
And we were going down a river in a craft just like theirs,
And we learned a lot of things.
I mean, that boat didn't have much of a key on it,
So if you put the sail up and the wind came in sideways,
that boat skidded sideways
And David was very polite, not to say.
but what happened at the very end of the trip was:
I'm standing on the bank watching the bat toe
come down the river
And I suddenly realized they're not going to bake to the bank
And the next bout is 50 more miles ahead.
But they ended up, as David said,
a quarter mile down the river, with David and Brandon Hayes
diving into the river and grabbing the bow rope
and throwing up on the bank
And everybody slowly pulled.
Part of my original plan was for them to actually experience
what it was like to pull that bat toe up the Missouri River,
One of those serendipitous moments
where at the very end of the trip they got that experience.
I also had everybody wear period clothes.
So, David, what is that like?
Well, I fell into the river on the first day-
Not actually when we were on the river,
I was getting out of my canoe and fell right into mud.
So then I was covered in mud and water
for the rest of the trip.
But I actually wore a Coonskin hat the entire time,
which got pretty hot during the day
because it's all leather on the inside,
But I didn't have to worry about it blowing away in the wind
and then by the end of the week I was pretty used to it
and it felt kind of weird not wearing a leather hat.
You got a real taste of an authentic historical experience.
Yeah,
Not necessarily always like something you might choose to do.
No, it wouldn't have been something
that I probably would have thought of
if Mr Malone hadn't suggested it,
But it ended up being fun.
I mean, it's one of those crazy things
where it's a real challenge
and it's not real pleasant while you're doing it
and it kind of hurts and it's hot,
but it turns out to be fun in the end.
Yeah,
So the elements for this: first of all,
Mike, you have a passion for history
That kind of keeps you motivated
and lights your fire about doing these things.
You also build in an element of service
is something that to me, would be uniquely scouting.
I don't think that would be the first thing
people would think of in putting a trip like this together,
but that is an added dimension to it.
that also is a big motivating factor,
Hopefully. I think that's the heart of the trip.
It begins sort of like scouting itself.
Scouting hooks you with the camping
and the knife and the fire
and all that, and the ropes
and all that and the knots and everything.
That's how scouting lures you in.
but ultimately scouting is about service
And these trips are the same thing.
I mean, we have the high concept,
which is Lewis and Clark or Civil War
or Cowboys driving cattle,
But at the heart of it,
what they come away with is
they've made a major contribution on it.
We restored a number of miles
of the Chisholm Trail,
repainting the old concrete posts,
And that's now playing a crucial role
in getting the Chisholm Trail
National Historic Trail status in Congress.
That's what's going to be in the spring
And they're using some of our work
and publicity
as part of making the case for that-
The Civil War one.
the results are going to be the reenactors
going to go out there
and see something really historically correct
and beautiful
And he was to say the people of Montana
just got themselves a beautiful new exhibit
at their museum.
They're going to have a historic trail
And, David, I think I have a pretty good idea
of what attracted you to participate
in these types of things.
What was the selling point for you?
Basically, it's just the great summer adventure.
I hit the opportunity to go spend a week
with my friends that are in the troop
doing some awesome trip
that Mr Malone has put together,
something that I would never be able to do
if someone hadn't proposed it.
I never would have thought of traveling to Virginia
and reenacting the Civil War
or flying out to Montana
to do a Lewis and Clark canoe trip,
But when the idea was proposed to me,
it sounded like something that would be
a great way to spend a week or two in the summer
and get a really unique experience
and not very many other people
have gotten the chance to do before.
What was the youth role in preparing
and getting everybody on the trip
and then conducting the trip itself?
On both trips we had a SPL for the trip
who would basically run a lot of the things
on the trip. but before the trip
we would have meetings every other week
to figure out how the planning of the trip
is going and discuss things.
A lot of times it would be scouts
that would bring up ideas
for what gear would need to be brought
or how food would work and things like that.
For my Eagle project
I ended up doing a large bulk of the work
for figuring out how to actually get the bateau
from New York to Montana
and coordinating with the Interpretive Center
and the Maritime Center
and just figuring out how we could get that there
so we could actually have the trip.
Pretty extensive preparation
and pretty extensive work on your part
as a youth leader in this.
I'm adding that to my list
So far we've got. there's passionate vision
that just really lights somebody's fire
and they say, wow, this would be a great thing to do.
You add to that an element of service.
I'm going to repeat myself in saying
that's not the first thing most people would think of.
I think that's a huge part of this.
And then you also have the element of
involving youth in leading and planning
and thinking it through.
I mean it just sounds like a wonderful thing
to be able to do.
Let me add a couple more things to the list.
One of them is value-added experiences,
And that is once you've got the core trip put together,
and once that's happened,
I typically hand over the logistics
to a mom or a dad.
The details are
because we're a boy-run troop.
the details go to this SPL
and the scouts that are their Eagle projects,
And then I go off
and start looking for value-added things.
So we went to the Charlie Russell Museum.
I found out that the State Fair was going on.
Literally, when I got there
in Great Falls, I found out the State Fair was going on,
So I called the PR director
and I said, hey, you know
we do a historical flag ceremony.
We have seven flags that we tell this whole thing
and unfurl the flags.
And she said: come on over, let's do it.
So we ended up in front of a big crowd in front of a concert
doing a flag ceremony.
I locate any historic trail patches,
metals that the boys can learn.
So they earned four of them when they were going to Virginia.
I keep adding more and more stuff
until every second of the trip is completely filled.
Some of those things turn out to be busts,
Some of them turn out to be the best part of some of the trips.
And the next thing is: you've got to be flexible and adaptable.
Something strange will happen,
Something will go wrong.
There's a lot of improvisation going on in these things.
That's the next factor: adaptability.
And then the final one is, and that's publicity.
Publicity is not that hard.
You just have to know who to call
and figure out what your hooks are.
when we did the Chisholm Trail,
Every TV station and newspaper in Oklahoma covered this,
And then we ended up on a cover of Scouting Magazine
And Boy's Life is doing a cover story
on the Lewis and Clark trip.
So what's the next big once-in-a-lifetime adventure?
Well, I try to keep it secret from the truth as best I can,
in part because I want them to be surprised and thrilled
and in part because I can't guarantee
it's going to happen until right about now.
Right, yeah,
I'd love to do that, sailing on the coast
of the Northwest in a square rig.
That would be an amazing experience.
The other big one I would love to do-
and I'm going to have to figure out
how to get one of these Silicon Valley companies
to help sponsor it-
I'd like to take the boys to Africa.
I've spent a lot of time in Africa.
My son's Eagle project- my oldest son-
he got an Adams Award for it-
was working with an orphanage in Zambia.
I'd like to take the boys back to that orphanage
And I'd also like, toward the Hornaday
I'd like to reintroduce a white rhino,
or a mating pair of white rhinos, to Namibia.
I have a friend there that said
I'd like to bring a couple rhinos in Namibia
and have the boys help out doing that,
then go work in this AIDS orphanage in Zambia.
I think that's an amazing trip.
David does that. if I put a rope in your hand
and there's a white rhino at the other end,
you're in right?
Oh, of course
I mean because a white rhino
is only a little bit bigger than a bat-toe.
It might weigh a bit more,
I would imagine, but that would.
that sounds like an amazing trip to me.
These are things of like immense scope
and real vision.
Does anybody ever come along and just tell you
that you're nuts and this is not going to work?
I think they've come to believe
I can pull off miracles.
You just kind of have a moxie to go after it.
That's what it comes down to.
I think I'm a Silicon Valley Algae Entrepreneur at heart.
I want you to take this the right way,
but you're nothing special.
I mean, this is not something that would be impossible
for other people to do.
Not at all, especially if you
delegate the responsibilities
and the scouts really carry the ball
for the core of the trip. you know the service.
I mean, that's their job-
to put that together and deal with the adults.
That's what an Eagle Project is.
So that takes care of itself.
You just got to have the. you know
the guts to go for it
And you're not tired of doing this yet.
No, I find it very intriguing.
What have the implications been for the trip?
The word about these trips gotten out there?
I mean, is it caused some excitement
about Troop 466??
I know our scout master, Dave Holt.
he says that one of the things he hears
of this is the reason that these parents
are bringing their little weeblos to the 466
is because they've heard about these trips
and they hope one day to do it.
If I'm going to put something like this together,
or if anybody listening begins to catch on
and they think that this is a great idea,
we need a little creativity,
We need to bring it together
with a little creativity,
We need to brass to be able to say,
hey, this is going to actually happen,
so let's start moving forward.
And then those other elements we talked about.
This is the right time of year
to start sparking people's ideas
about something big for next summer.
Mike, you're a reporter
and an author and you're completing
a book
to be published in 2012
about the history of Eagle Scouting.
Eagle Scouting turns
into a hundred next year.
And is this a
BSA book?
It's going to be a BSA book.
The museum and archives have opened up
all of their photographs,
So it should be a major, major book.
You probably see it in every Boy Scout
to shop next year.
Well, hopefully, as soon as it comes out,
we'll get back together.
We'll put you on the podcast again and talk about it,
Deal?
I read the same feeling in your blog,
which is: it's a great honor
to work with these kids.
When you're talking about
kids that are on their way to Eagle,
you're really dealing with extraordinary
young men and it's just an honor
to be able to
help them have great adventures.
I'm sure they appreciate it.
It's great work that you're doing.
I really appreciate you guys taking the time
and I hope we can talk again sometime.
Yeah, thanks, Clark, Take care.
Thank you,
Music.
Well, thanks for listening,
and here's how to keep in touch.
You can read the Scoutmaster blog
at scoutmastercgcom
and, while you're there,
you can subscribe to the Scoutmaster newsletter,
which is a monthly digest of the Scoutmaster blog
and podcast with some great
scouting resources around a monthly theme,
and every newsletter includes
a giveaway from one of our affiliate sponsors.
You can subscribe to the
Scoutmaster podcast on iTunes
and, when you do, feel free to leave a comment
or review or a rating
and you can call me.
Alright, you can call
at 4-8-4-7-3-4-0-0-0-2
and you can
leave a voicemail message
that can be included in
an upcoming edition of the Scoutmaster
Music
And keep in touch with what's going on.
you can follow us at Scoutmaster blog
on Facebook and Scoutmaster
CG on Twitter.
You can email me,
Clark Green, with all your comments and questions
at
scoutmastercg
at Verizonnet.
That's Scoutmaster
CG
at Verizonnet
Music.
Music,
The Scoutmaster blog and the Scoutmaster podcast
are not official publications
of the Boy Scouts of America,
nor are they endorsed or sponsored
by the Boy Scouts of America. Hey,
it's just me and I have a microphone
and I like to talk
and try to lend a hand to scout leaders
and maybe have a little bit of fun along the way.
Music
And finally, before we go,
we want to hear from
the founder of Scouting,
Sir Robert Baden-Pal.
Sir Robert,
Good luck to you and good camping.
Well, thank you, sir,
Until next time.
Music
End.